moment très attendu de ce salon du
bourget les démonstrations en vol et
particulièrement la voltige aérienne
le public nombreux a pu admirer la
patrouille de france mais également ses
petits avions des caps 10 basée à saint
cyr l'école sur le terrain de l'aéro
club
ils appartiennent à laval amicale de
voltige aérienne qui a formé de nombreux
pilotes
le club possède plusieurs modèles
monoplace ou biplace et comprend une
centaine de membres à sa tête
régis alajouanine qui a créé le club il
ya 37 ans c'est une légende de
l'aviation qui fabriquent tous ses
avions
l'amicale de voitures et rien ne les
crée en 1980 sa fête à 37 ans a autour
d'agapes disent qu'on a toujours avec
notre avion fétiche et depuis bas avec
toute l'équipe de bénévoles que j'ai on
a fait toutes choses on a re permis aux
caps de revoler après un accident
on a fait des modifications on a fait
évoluer les câbles et on ait des avions
qui sont champions du lion du monde avec
des champions et des championnes comme
god le mordant qui est encore championne
du monde qui a été championne du monde
au texas avec notre cadre de 332
démonstration avec ce cap 432 véritable
formule 1 des airs qui participent au
championnat du monde de voltige aérienne
le pilote atteint la vitesse de 405 km
heure avec des accélérations de plus ou
moins 9 g soit neuf fois le poids de son
corps à son bord benoît mériaux un
pilote d'exception
ingénieur chez dassault aviation il faut
aimer se concentrer il faut aimer
des sensations assez forte et un certain
physique aujourd'hui la particularité
c'est elle à très haute température on
va dire il faut aimer la rigueur et il
faut aimer se remettre en question ce
qui est parfois très difficile pour
l'ego le pilote très concentré se
focalise sur les figures maintes fois
répété il enchaîne les tonneaux et les
figures
c'était aussi la première démonstration
en vol pour dorine bourneton régis
alajouanine a modifié un avion pour que
cette jeune femme paraplégique à la
suite d'un accident d'avion à l'âge de
16 ans puissent à nouveau évoluer seul
dans les airs j'ai commencé ma formation
de voltige ya deux ans à peu près et
aujourd'hui j'ai hâte un deuxième cycle
de voltige et à ce titre j'ai pu faire
une démonstration de voltige ici au
bourget parce que je suis la première
femme handicapée au monde pilotes de
voltige
grâce à ces modifications techniques des
commandes manuelles à la main elle peut
piloter le premier avion équipé pour une
personne handicapée
je suis super fier parce qu'après avoir
un accident d'avion à l'âge de 16 ans
c'est une belle revanche